well the national guard in Hawaii is
warning of new immediate dangers to
people living near the Kilauea Volcano
some two and a half months after the
eruption began at the same time the
massive flow of lava into the ocean is
reshaping the big island Carter Evans is
in Pahoa Hawaii where the lava is
creating hundreds of acres of new land
where the ocean used to be good morning
the eruption behind me here is what's
pushing this massive river of molten
lava on an 8 mile journey to the ocean
it is literally changing the outline of
the island itself and it continues to do
so every day as lava threatens even more
of the coastline the continuous lava
flow has now covered about 12 and a half
square miles of Hawaii's Big Island
about half the size of Manhattan destroy
more than 700 homes and still
threatening many more we're hearing the
mandatory evacuation area there's an
ever-present immediate danger
sulfur dioxide levels wind shift the
immediate threat from the lava lava has
been pouring into the ocean for more
than eight weeks now this is new
coastline the island has grown by nearly
700 acres the equivalent of more than
500 football fields before this new
eruption started in early May a map of
Hawaii South East region looked like
this but then lava filled Kapoho Bay
expanding the coastline farther and
farther into the sea at one point a
small island was formed off the coast
scientists think molten lava broke
through a hardened rock crust under
water rising until it reached above sea
level it's been difficult Michael Hale
is one of a reported 1,500 evacuees a
lava field now covers the area that used
to be his home in May video captured
lava engulfed in his car he now lives in
a makeshift home with limited power are
you going to stay I'm gonna stay since
I've moved here I've always wanted to be
here like I could go somewhere else rent
an apartment but I don't know this is my
home
his property like so many others is now
covered with black hardened rock and
it's unclear if the state will ever
allow them to rebuild so for hundreds of
people here their futures are still
uncertain even once this crisis is over
for CBS this morning Carter Evans Pahoa
Hawaii